I did this audition and I got the job
and it was Wes Craven and I do really I
do really have him to thank because that
was before lovely and amazing actually
and I wouldn't have got lovely and
amazing
I'm I'm sure if it hadn't been for the
fact that I've already been in a movie
and done an American accent
and he was a real advocate of mine and I
loved working with him I just think he
was the most gentle intelligent quiet
soft-spoken guy but with just such a
great humor and intelligence and such a
kind person and he he really sort of
took to me for some reason and they did
a parachute em you know these filmmakers
made little shorts set in Paris and it
was the first one and he chose me for
that and then and I did this hadn't shot
with him and then and then a big that
the filmmakers were approached and asked
to do dress up their kind of New Year's
or whatever I don't know as as movie's
famous movie stars and and he chose me
and as and dress me up as as as Audrey
Hepburn for the New York Times and I
felt like he was a sort of mentor and he
promoted me and he definitely paved the
way in a way for for people like Nicole
or Horace and others to feel good about
customer things
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]